qu'on se le dise en ce moment du côté du
comité miss france rien ne va plus alors
que cette année le concours célèbre son
centenaire une autre tradition commence
tout doucement à s'inscrire dans
l'histoire
les miss évincé en raison de photos
dénudées après la disqualification danel
gains by miss guadeloupe qui en
septembre dernier a été évincé du
concours en raison de la publication de
photos dénudées puis anastasia salvi
miss franche comté qui quelques semaines
plus tard a quant à elle été destitué
c'est aujourd'hui naïma des sous qui est
au coeur de la polémique
une fois encore c'est une histoire de
photo qui est au centre du problème des
photos jugées non conformes par le
comité qui a décidé tout de même de
laisser naïma des souhaits exercer son
rôle de miss saint martin saint
barthélémy 2020 en revanche elle ne
représentera pas sa région lors de
l'élection nationale
un troisième cas qui interroge sur ce
règlement très strict qui semble de plus
en plus difficile à faire appliquer
auprès de la nouvelle génération
[Musique]
alors en fait les photos sont des photos
faites dans un cadre privé et ça a été
envoyée directement dans les deux sens
c'est une horreur à paris elle n'était
pas sur internet les zones non au comité
à l'organisation massacrant six poteaux
privée donc c'est quelqu'un a eu accès à
ces photos privées et non ça c'est un
anonyme photos privées en voyage à paris
c'est la photo sexy oui c'est des photos
sexy je les ai pas vus mais on m'a dit
qu'on allait faire des résumés road la
personne qui sait tout de limiter
régional le comité régional mais pas
d'accord ce qui lui laisse son titre
régional
mais comme paris n'en veut pas il n'y
aura pas de représentant de miss un
homme se trouve à elle émis au concours
national à sa mêlée à la roquette bien
sûr responsable bien entendu people ce
qui est sûr c'est ce qu'on a appris
séquelles et les photos ne sont ni
vulgaire ni érotique ni porno donc le
comité de saab à la maintient à ce
comité là donc il ya une contradiction
et la refuse au comité national dont je
crois que ça va devenir aux tic ni
vulgaire ni porno ça peut produire aux
fans est en train de faire quand même
l'idée que ces concours de beauté année
gensac au compte gouttes et moi je serai
au comité je rendrai même obligatoire
les photos de nu artistique
pourquoi un concours de beauté
maintenant ils sont en train de nous à
les dernières photos nues que j'ai vu
c'est c'est dommage mais on peut le dire
une poitrine
la manif avait vraiment oui mais j'ai
envie comment veux tu aller à l'encontre
d'un règlement quand tu participes à
changer le règlement et bafoue maladie
plutôt que tu me changer le règlement
mais après pas aller à l'encontre après
comme bernard tu dis que c'est ni
vulgaire ni pardon ni ce que tu veux ça
je suis désolé mais c'est le jugement de
propre à chacun ça veut dire qu'il ya
des plus grands soirs j'ai retrouvé sa
bulle guerre des gens qui vont trouver
ça moins vulgaire ça c'est différent
après moi je suis totalement contre la
délation donc la personne surtout c
était bien de photos privées mais je
comprends le comité qui fit prendre en
compte ces photos au chaos qu'elle sorte
après sûr je vais vous dire le seul qui
a des infos sur les photos c'est bernard
montiel ou donc je pense que c'est lui